why is it so bad to use credit cards if
you can use them responsibly I see no
issue in using them to build credit and
earn rewards so whatever what advice can
you guys give me the truth is even if
you pay it off perfectly
every single study we've ever seen shows
that you spend more when you use a
credit card
which would by the way negate the two
percent you might be making off the card
and by the way if there's a single
misstep you're now being charged 22
percent
interest
every single time you carry that balance
and the studies show one uh 48 of people
pay off their card every month which
means 52 percent don't
and that's if they were telling the
truth we don't know if 48 were actually
telling the truth there but MIT has done
a study on this then they found with
fmri technology they examine the brain
during the point of purchase and they
found that the use of credit cards
activates the reward networks of the
brain which acts like a gas pedal
causing you to spend more